hey what's up folks down here at GS news
updates the week you finally pick up an
Xbox one may be upon us that's right
gamestop are having themselves a little
sale running from jun 27 to the 28th
across all the gamestop stores in the US
the stale gives discounts on Xbox one
accessories as well as a 50-percent
bonus on a console traded in towards an
Xbox one purchase according to gamestop
slatest trade value chart an xbox 360's
system will get you around 75 bucks so
with a 50-percent bonus you'd get one
hundred and twelve dollars towards an
xbox one a 500 gigabyte ps3 k model
normally goes for eighty dollars so with
the bonus that's 120 bucks if you choose
to pick up a kinect list 399 dollar xbox
one you could grab it for in two hundred
and eighty dollars an Xbox one purchase
will also get you twenty dollars off a
12-month xbox live subscription normally
that's priced at forty dollars and ten
dollars of an extra wireless controller
which is normally fifty dollars they
also have discounts on xbox one games
and accessories and them the Amazon
Kindle Fire HD if you want one of those
things for more xbox one news stay tuned
to gamestop games 5